- Okay, so this is the TCL 40 NXTPAPER,
and at first glance, it might not appear
to be a particularly special phone.
Like, this is a $200 budget Android phone.
It's got a 5000 milliamp power battery,
a pretty standard issue
50 megapixel main camera
flanked by a 5 megapixel ultrawide
and a two megapixel macro,
and inside, a Mediatek G88
processor, 8 gigs of RAM,
and 256 gigs of storage.
This design is pretty basic.
It's squared up, nothing too offensive,
a solid blue color with
some sparkles in it,
but it has exactly one
really interesting feature
that's caught my attention,
and that's the screen.
So this screen, you're
looking at a 6.78 inch,
flat, 1080p, 90 hertz display,
but when you put it up
next to another phone,
that's when you immediately notice
something is very different about it,
mainly that there are no
reflections at all, none,
well, almost none,
so this phone is called the NXTPAPER
because it has what TCL is calling
a full-color electronic paper display
to deliver a reflection-free, full-color,
paper-like visual experience,
which looks way better,
has much less fatigue on the eyes,
and also feels better in the hand.
And so my first thought,
when I first saw this,
was, okay, why doesn't
every phone have this?
Like, how is it a super cheap budget phone
that's the first one I've
seen to pull this off,
and why aren't more phones doing this?
What am I missing here?
And so of course, I had to use
it to get all these answers.
So, okay, TCL calls it the NXTPAPER
because they'd like you to think of it
as just like an e-paper display.
If you've ever seen a Kindle
or any of the other various
E Ink displays out there,
that tech is actually
kinda sick, it's amazing.
It minimizes fatigue on the eyes,
and it looks and feels like
something's literally printed
on a piece of paper, like an
newspaper, in front of you.
It works great in all
sorts of different lighting
because it's literally
rearranging actual ink
underneath the display.
But this is actually not that.
Instead, it's an LCD display
with a textured glass on top
and some software tricks to
resemble a paper-like display
and deliver almost all of
the eye comfort benefits
that come with it,
so the result is basically
what looks like a normal smartphone screen
with zero reflections,
and I am very into that.
Like, look at this screen
next to a glossy regular
smartphone glass screen.
Typically, when I review phones,
like, I have to spend a lot of effort
shielding these displays from reflections.
That's a little known fact in this,
I guess it's kinda inside baseball,
but when you shoot reflective
things, it is a challenge.
I have to angle the phone certain ways,
I have to shoot in certain environments,
and I often use what we call a flag here,
which is literally just to
slide it in at a certain angle
to block reflections and make
the screen easier to see.
It's a whole thing.
But with this matte display,
I mean, I just don't need any
of that special treatment,
like, it's happy to show up at any angle,
and the angles that would
normally have a giant reflection,
it just kinda looks a little bit lighter,
a little faded, but
still actually readable,
and then when you're straight on,
or just kinda regularly reading,
it's nice and soft, and it's
less stressful on the eyes.
It is kinda weirdly a
little bit paper-like,
like some of those paper-like displays.
So almost all of this
is enabled by hardware,
so there are a bunch of extra layers
between the actual LCD display and you,
including this textured glass,
and so that's all what gives
it this anti-reflective look.
There's also some other benefits,
like physically limiting
the amount of blue light
that makes it through,
so instead of a special
mode in the software,
there is just physically less blue light
making it through an additional filter
into your eyes.
And another underrated one, the feel.
I mean, literally, the way the glass feels
under your finger.
It kinda has this soft touch effect
thanks to the slight texture.
So you can actually see the difference
up at the cutout at the top.
You obviously can't do textured glass
over the front-facing camera,
because that would ruin the photos,
not that they're amazing
photos in the first place,
but that's the most obvious spot
where you can see that difference
between the matte finish and glossy glass.
And my finger just runs over this glass
almost the same way that it
does on the back of the phone.
(rubbing with no sound)
(rubbing creates swishing)
So I think all this is
shaping up to be pretty cool,
the matte finish, the
basically zero reflections,
the much lower eye strain,
the soft touch finish.
There's also stylus support,
as TCL makes a stylus
that actually works with
this type of screen.
So what's the catch?
Why don't more phones have this on them?
And you're probably one
step ahead of me already,
which is, yeah, there are some downsides.
So first of all,
a bunch of extra layers
on the display itself
is gonna have some obvious drawbacks,
but mainly, it's just that
they're cutting a lot of light,
like, it hurts a lot of sharpness
and just total light
getting through to you.
So this is the absolute
maximum 100% brightness
of this screen,
and it's 450 nits,
so it's good enough to read
indoors, as you've seen,
but outdoors, it's gonna get
pretty quickly washed out
and is disappointingly dim.
Now, again, this is a $200 phone,
so I think if this was
an even higher-end phone
with a brighter LCD or an OLED back there,
maybe it could solve or
help some of these issues,
but that wouldn't fix the
other one, which is sharpness.
So this is a 1080p display, as I've said,
but it doesn't even really look like that.
I mean, I think if I asked you
what resolution you think this is,
or if I did a blind test or something,
it would compare pretty
closely to a 720p display.
I mean, text is soft,
edges of things are soft,
all the corners are soft.
It just all kinda has a little
bit of a glow to the edges,
which, again, makes things
nice and easy to look at,
like nothing is harsh, or super bright,
or fatiguing on the eyes,
but if it's a sharp photo or
a video detail you're after,
then putting a bunch of layers
between your eyeballs
and the actual display
is not the best way to see those details.
And then same thing with contrast.
Just because of how much
brightness is limited,
the lack of contrast
becomes really obvious.
This one's rated at just
1500:1 contrast ratio,
which, even when compared
to other budget phones,
is not that great.
Oh, and then screen protectors.
People usually put screen
protectors on their phones,
and this one would
obviously not make sense
to put a screen protector on (chuckling).
So suddenly, in this world
of feature-rich smartphones
with all these big,
bright, clear displays,
this goes from being an advantage
to being a niche feature (chuckles),
because most people aren't willing
to sacrifice the downsides
that come with maybe a
little bit less eye strain
and less reflections
for a matte display.
This isn't like a desktop screen,
where most people are buying it
just based on the panel and
the visual display properties.
There's a bunch of stuff about
a phone people care about,
and it turns out people do
not like that trade-off.
So I've talked about all
kinds of other niche features
in the smartphone world,
and how they're awesome
but won't actually sell a ton of phones.
This is, like, the perfect
addition to that pile.
I mean, TCL has these
special NXTPAPER modes
in the software,
and when you turn one of them on,
one's called color paper,
and it goes the extra mile
to, you know, turn down
saturation a little bit
and reduce the extra-vibrant colors.
it adds some texture,
and everything,
it literally looks like
your smartphone screen
is, like, a colored piece of paper,
with, like, your icons in
colored ink, moving around.
And then you can go all
the way up to ink paper,
which goes full black and white.
It seems silly to most people,
but when you compare it to
an actual E Ink display,
that's when it looks amazing.
Like, an actual e-reader
is the least fatiguing
version on your eyes,
but if you've ever used one,
you know that frame rates are pretty slow,
Like, you can hardly get
like, even a real
page-turning book animation
on some of the absolute
bleeding-edge best versions we have,
so a smartphone with a
special hardware layer
that gets close to the same visual level
but is 90 hertz, fully
responsive, full color,
and can do anything your phone can do
on top of being an e-reader,
is technically awesome,
which is why TCL also makes
a tablet version of this
and another phone version of this.
It is super cool, but almost
no one's gonna buy it,
and that's why not every other phone
is going out to do this too,
at least for now, anyway.
Thanks for watching.
Catch you guys the next one.
Peace.